mais tout à coup le serpent on se
retrouve face à un poisson de sable
celui ci très agressif face à l'attack
mais il rate son coup plus rapide il
hume en la mâchoire inférieure
désemparé la couleuvre cherchent à se
libérer une fois son de sable avec ses
mâchoires redoutable ne lâche pas prise
le serpent qui croyait avoir une proie
facile se retrouve en position délicate
[Musique]
la confrontation entre les reptiles a
parfois des témoins impassible le
caméléon observe cette lutte parfois
fratricides
[Musique]
les espèces se dévorent entre elles
dans ce cas le caméléon s'éloigne
toujours il continuera à observer la
scène du haut de l'arbre le plus proche
[Musique]
la façon dont les serpents s'alimente a
toujours impressionné les hommes la
mobilité de leurs mâchoires leur permet
d'avaler des proies plus grande que et
de se déformer pour les engloutit
[Musique]